Boom the bad guy just broke into your
system and you are hemorrhaging data you
have had a data breach how much is it
going to cost you how long is it going
to take you to get everything back up
and operational again well we answer
those questions in the annual cost of a
data breach report and what I want to
share with you today are the methodology
that we use in order to get these
numbers what some of the key findings
from the report are and then ultimately
some recommendations that you can use in
order to cut the cost of a data breach
and reduce the amount of time it takes
to recover so let's start off with
methodology
what did we do in order to get the
information that we have so that you can
have confidence that the numbers I'm
about to share with you mean anything in
the real world well we started off by
Contracting with an organization called
The ponymon Institute and they do this
work on behalf of IBM so the clients who
are answering these questions are not
answering directly to us they feel like
they can be candid in their responses
and we've run this now for 18 years so
I'm going to suggest to you some of you
haven't learned the lessons of the
previous 17 so pay close attention to
this one please
the clients that we interviewed we
talked to More Than 3 000 individual
clients ponderman Institute did on our
behalf and those people represented 533
different organizations so the point
here being is there was a large number
of people contributing their information
we didn't just go out and ask three
people and find out what they thought
this is a large empirical base of data
that we're basing all of this on and
another interesting part of the out of
the methodology is the outliers were
excluded and what that means is if you
think about the cost of a data breach
some people will have very minimal costs
they'll have a very small breach and
some people will have really huge ones
this one would be a gajillion dollars
this one would be 25 cents I guess and
the point is we're excluding the ones on
either extreme because those would skew
the numbers and they would make the
averages not look very realistic so we
take those out the very small the very
large and we focus in just on the
normative case so that we can have some
lessons that we can apply elsewhere
now let's take a look at some of the key
findings that came out of this first of
all
4.45 million dollars is the cost of a
data breach worldwide that's the average
cost some are more some are less the
ones that are more
10.43 million dollars in the U.S if
you're a Health Care Organization that
was the highest of all the industries
that we looked at so if you're working
in health care I would say pay special
attention to this because that number is
not going to be sustainable too
expensive
now what were the things that were
contributing to this there's a lot of
different ways that data can be breached
a lot of different ways bad guys get in
so if we look at cost of different types
of attacks and frequency of those then
put those two together the things that
are highest cost and highest frequency
are the ones that are contributing most
to those numbers so what were they well
the top two it turns out the top one was
phishing attacks
and just behind it were attacks that
deal with credential compromise so these
are some things that if we want to
reduce those numbers we really need to
focus on these kinds of attack scenarios
now what else did we learn from this
some other numbers that I think are
important maybe one of the most
depressing numbers even more depressing
than those numbers are these numbers
I've talked about this in previous
videos the the basic timeline of an
attack so a bad guy comes in and does
initially this reconnaissance phase
where he's looking and trying to figure
out what's going to happen then there's
an attack that's the boom then we have a
mean time to identify that's how long it
takes for us to figure out that in fact
we've been breached and then we have a
mean time to contain that's how long it
takes for us to resolve whatever the
issue is
and the thing that's really depressing
here these two numbers taken together
277 days that's a really long time for
the bad guy to be in your system using
your data and then for you once you
realize it to come up and figure out how
to fix this the the depressing part
about this is not only is that a long
time but it's been essentially the same
number for almost the last 10 years in
other words we keep trying new
technologies new processes procedures we
promise we're going to do better we're
all going to try harder but this number
remains so clearly we've got a lot of
lessons to learn if we're going to get
ahead on this and reduce costs and
reduce the amount of time that it takes
to contain to identify and contain all
right let's move on to recommendations
that's the bad news there's some good
news in the report as well and some of
that good news is that I'm going to
share with you the top three things that
made a difference in reducing the cost
of a data breach and those top three in
order reverse order so number three
1.49 million came a reduction came from
good incident response planning tools
procedures processes training all of
that kind of stuff if you've got good
instant response you're doing things in
this side and you're doing the
containment much better and the quicker
you contain the less it's going to cost
the next one 1.68 million this resulted
this savings from a good deployment of
devsecops
devsecops is basically Breaking Down the
Walls between development and operations
and inserting security throughout the
process as part of a a systemic view so
we've got no longer throwing stuff over
the wall we've got development security
and operations all working together
through a continuous process of
improvement
number one to improve the cost of a data
breach in other words reduce the cost
this was the use of AI and automation
and that makes a lot of sense we want to
work smarter we want to work faster more
efficiently in a more repeatable way and
that's what Ai and automation allow us
to do respectively and if you take those
numbers that and look at just the AI and
Automation and see what difference did
that in fact make well that's what these
numbers here are so for organizations
that really had no AI to any real extent
really we're not taking advantage of it
this was the cost for them 5.36 million
the ones who had done limited uh use of
AI well you notice a significant savings
here down to about 4 million and then
for those who had an extensive use of AI
it was down to 3.6 million and one of
the other side benefits is that it was
108 days reduction in the amount of time
to resolve so the AI and automation not
only reduce cost it also reduced the
response time and resolution time time
this is clearly a big winner that's why
you see the three stars and I'm going to
throw in a bonus no extra charge a bonus
recommendation that will also make a big
difference and that's attack surface
management attack surface management is
basically trying to look and see all the
different things that you look like to
an attacker and reducing that
plugging the holes and in some cases
fortifying your defenses so attack
surface management really begins with
awareness of what your attack surface
looks like and then putting the controls
in place in order to make those not part
of the attack surface anymore and attack
surface management organizations
according to the to the survey that did
the best with this reduced their time to
contain so that mean time to contain uh
83 days that was a significant number if
you can do something like this you're
going to reduce the response you're
going to reduce the cost and if you do
all of these kinds of things you're
going to make a huge huge difference in
your data breach numbers
so it turns out I'm going to give you
also a bonus finding that we got from
the report that's kind of a good news
bad news story here and that is of the
organization's 51 percent said they
would increase their spending in I.T
Security in cyber security
good they realized that we need to do
something here and tools and better
training and things like that they cost
money but they make us money by saving
us in these areas but I do have a
question for the other 49 did you not
just read all of this did you not hear
please take a look at the report because
once you see it you're going to see the
things that are going to make a big
difference and you're going to be able
to make a better impact for your
organization and that will impact the
bottom line so in the end I'm going to
recommend that you take a look at the
report the cost of a data breach report
it's for free so you can go to the
following link and take a look read
through the results and figure out what
it is you need to do what's going to
make the biggest difference in improving
the cost of a data breach for your
organization
hey before you go remember to hit like
subscribe and click the Bell so that
you're notified whenever we come out
with more videos